Marvel has been incredibly careful about making
sure that no real Avengers: Endgame spoilers
slip out prior to the film's April 26th release,
instituting strict controls over access to
the script, and scaring the stars into complete
radio silence.
"I've been sort of put under surveillance
by Marvel."
"They don't want you talking about anything."
"They got a lot of reach in the world."
So it's kind of ironic that one big spoiler
might have gotten out thanks to Marvel accidentally
including it in their own trailers!
Yes, it's true.
Eagle-eyed fans pouring over every frame of
the recent Avengers: Endgame trailer discovered
that there's apparently a discrepancy between
the normal version and the 3-D version — and
that difference reveals the return of some
bad guys from Avengers: Infinity War.
It happens during the scene where Jeremy Renner's
Hawkeye runs down a tunnel to escape a big
explosion.
Nothing spoilery there, right?
But Reddit user andresgarcia102 discovered
that in the 3-D version of the trailer, two
figures can be seen chasing him.
Based on the appearance of the figures, it
appears as though the bad guys are none other
than the Outriders — the henchmen in Thanos's
employ who aided in the assault on Wakanda
during Infinity War.
What's interesting here isn't just the fact
that the Outriders seem to be rearing their
ugly, xenomorph-esque heads in Endgame — it's
also that they aren't seen in the 2D Endgame
trailer, only in the 3D footage.
This suggests pretty strongly that Marvel
may have purposefully altered the footage
in the normal trailer in order to prevent
any spoilers from leaking.
But apparently this detail was missed when
they were editing the 3D version — and naturally,
Marvel's rabid Avengers fans discovered it
right away.
This is far from the first time Marvel filmmakers
— namely Joe and Anthony Russo, who are
responsible for Infinity War, Endgame, and
Captain America: Civil War — have screwed
around with footage in their trailers as a
means to keep plot details protected.
Most famously, the first trailers for Infinity
War included a sequence where the Avengers
team, which had assembled to defend Wakanda,
included the Hulk.
However, Hulk isn't anywhere to be seen during
the climactic battle, because he refused to
participate, forcing Bruce Banner to fight
using Iron Man's Hulkbuster armor.
Co-director Anthony Russo admitted that they
made up the scene with the Hulk just for the
trailer.
"That shot [...] was never in the movie in
the version that you saw.
It was never even created for the movie in
that version.
It was literally created in that version for
the trailer."
And his brother, co-director Joe Russo, said
they do that stuff all the time.
"We look at the trailer as a very different
experience than the movie, and I think audiences
are so predictive now that you have to be
very smart about how you craft a trailer because
an audience can watch a trailer and basically
tell you what’s gonna happen in the film.
[...] So at our disposal are lots of different
shots that aren’t in the movie that we can
manipulate through CG to tell a story that
we want to tell specifically for the purpose
of the trailer and not for the film."
That does raise the possibility that the presence
of these Outriders are also an elaborate fake-out.
But considering they aren't in the normal
version of the trailer, it seems more likely
that they were erased from that version rather
than added to the 3D version.
Whatever the case, the big takeaway is that
even if this spoiler turns out to be correct,
you should take everything in the trailer
with a grain of salt, because any part of
it could be bogus.
Some fans, for instance, are already speculating
that the shot of Tony Stark walking with the
team in the 2nd trailer is a fake-out — and
we know that scene was heavily edited one
way or another, because a different version
with different characters appeared in the
first Super Bowl teaser.
There's only one way to know the truth, of
course, so… we'll see you in the theaters.
Looks like the trailers did their job after
all.
"Mark, that is enough!
That is enough spoilers!
We have to see the movie!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one!